une lueur d'espoir la vie reprend
timidement ses droits dans cette gare
madrilène pour ne prendre aucun nouveau
risque la police et des volontaires
distribuent 10 millions de masques pour
les employés essentiellement ceux de
l'industrie et de la construction
beaucoup de personnes reprennent le
travail aujourd'hui après ce congé payé
et à leur retour ils vous rencontrez les
gardes civils qui essaie d'assurer leur
sécurité est en outre qu'ils aident à
distribuer le matériel de protection
appropriées lorsqu'ils tentent de se
rendre au travail
je peux vous dire que jusqu'à présent la
journée s'est déroulée dans la plus
grande normale après deux semaines
d'hibernation cette opération rassure
les espagnols motivé à l'idée de
reprendre une activité
troisième pays le plus endeuillé au
monde depuis deux semaines seuls les
activités essentielles comme
l'alimentation la santé et l'énergie
étaient autorisés afin de donner un coup
de frein à la contagion
je pense que c'est très bien parce que
de cette façon nous évitons les
infections et c'est merveilleux que le
gouvernement passe tu là parce qu'il ya
des gens qui peut-être ils ne vendent
pas de masque où ils sont très chers
donc c'est parfait
oui je pense que c'est la bonne décision
tant que nous le faisons avec ses
mesures de sécurité
distribution quotidienne de masques de
protection transports publics fluide
dans lesquelles les wagons ne sont pas
emballés
je suis venu ici en métro et c'était
plutôt bien avec une distance de
sécurité d'un mètre et demi que je pense
qu'ils l'ont bien fait l'économie s'est
arrêté pendant longtemps et je pense que
de cette façon cela peut revenir avec la
sécurité les 47 millions d'espagnols
reste tout de même soumis à un
confinement des plus strictes seuls ceux
qui ne peuvent pas travailler de chez
eux sont autorisés à reprendre leurs
activités
les autres ne peuvent sortir que pour
acheter à manger aller à la pharmacie ou
sortir brièvement leur chien les
autorités de santé estiment que le pic
de la crise a été dépassé depuis les 960
nord enregistrent
le 2 avril dernier mais le président du
gouvernement pedro sanchez a prévenu la
population
ils sont encore loin de la victoire et
du jour où ils pourront reprendre une
vie normale